قتلى وجرحى في عمليه ثالثه بالقدس خلال
اسبوعين
لها ما بعدها من تاثير على حكومه اليمين
في اسرائيل عمليه الدهس نفذها حسين قراقع
من حي العيساوي بالقدس المحتله في محطه
الانتظار الحافلات في الحي الاستيطاني
ريموت شمالي القدس حيث كانت المحطه تقتضد
بالاسرائيليين في ذروه نهار الجمعه قبل ان
يقوم مستوطن وشرطي باطلاق النار على منفذ
العمليه من مسافه السفر وقتله
نحن نتقدم في التحقيق وبالامكان القول ان
منفذ العمليه هو من سكان القدس الشرقيه في
الثلاثين من عمره حيث قام بقياده سيارته
وتوجيهها مباشره الى محطه الحافلات واصاب
عددا ممن كانوا ينتظرون هناك
الى موقع العمليه وصل وزير الامن القومي
اتمر بن جير حيث توعد بتضييق الخناق على
ضاحيه العيسوي بالقدس المحتله واتخاذ مزيد
من الاجراءات لمواجهه ما سماه الارهاب
او عزو الى الشرطه بنشر الحواجز على ضاحيه
العيساويه وتوقيف كل سياره وتفتيشها اردت
ان افرض حصارا عن العيساويه لكن تمت عقبات
قضائيه سنبحث فيها لاحقا
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سارعت الى
اقتحام منزل منفذ العمليه واعتقلت زوجته
تحت تهديد السلاح بينما اوعز رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو بتسريع اغلاق المنزل
تمهيدا لهدمه وامر بتعزيز التدابير
الامنيه في القدس ومحيطها عمليه جديده في
القدس لا تنحصر نتائجها بما خلفته من قتلى
وجرحى بل تمتد ارتدادتها الى ما قد تحملوه
من ردود فعل من جانب الحكومه الاسرائيليه
اليمنيه التي وعدت الاسرائيليين بعهد
ليذكر الجزيره من موقع العمليه في مستوطنه
ريموت